hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar overview of the main hormones
associated with alteration of bone and
mineral metabolism in patients with
chronic kidney disease I'm Alexis Krause
of laberd's and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lappers and brought to you
by the asourian to learn more visit diaz
Lauren comm know let's get started
before you begin I would like to remind
everyone but this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
I didn't mean time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send well answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left ear screen this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I would
now like to present today's speaker
jean-claude su ba ba from x height of
labora de explorations functionalist
Ospital Necker and faun Miletus for
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
jean claude you may now begin your
presentation okay okay first hello
everybody I wish you for some a good
morning for some others good evening I
thought to where you you stay I will
speak today about the measurement in
chronic disease CKD of the hormones that
you are involved in bone and mineral
metabolism which are PTH vitamin D and
fgf 23 but before going deep into the
topic and would like
to remain you especially for those who
are not familiar with calcium phosphate
whatever is some basic physiology
acknowledge you all know that you're
neither consumer is very very tightly
regulated in fact any of its variation
is detected by the protein which is
called the calcium sensing receptor and
when can Samia increases the receptor is
activated when can Samia decreases the
receptor is inactivated in case of a
decrease in United Cal Samia
there is inactivation of the calcium
sun-sin receptor and an immediate
secretion of the party either omen PTH
which will work to increase can see Mia
and for this it will use three ways in
two ways are direct the release of
calcium by Boone and increase
reabsorption a decrease reproduction
increase reabsorption of calcium in the
distal tubular and one way is indirect
the PTH will stimulate the secretion of
the active metabolite of vitamin D which
is called can see trial or 125 D hydroxy
vitamin D in the proximal tubule and can
see trial will work in synergy with PTH
to increase consumer participating to
the release of calcium by the good and
to the increased reabsorption of calcium
in the distal tubule at also Kelsey
trial does something that PTH doesn't do
it will increase the absorption of
calcium by the goods and this will lead
to the normalization of unison calcium
also can see trial excerpts feedback on
the secretion of PTH by the parathyroid
glands you know that the kidney is the
main regulator of phosphate Amira and
the phosphate which is filtered that
chromodoris is almost entirely
reabsorbed in the proximal tubule and
the first rat Amir depends on the
quantity of phosphide the
is reabsorbed by the Protima proximal
tubule they are the sodium phosphate
cool transporter which are NPT 2a and
NPT to see further proteins and also we
have the activity of two almonds which
is one is PTH but again and the other
one is fgf 23 this is a very dramatic
representation of a proximal tubule of
Sailor you know the URI information is
here on the top of the slide it's called
the glomerular filtrate and the plasma
is here on the bottom of the slide these
two protein NPT 2a and in PT 2 C channel
protein that he'll know the reabsorption
of phosphate in the cell here and when
PTH and EDF 23 bind to the receptor to
the respective receptor there will
decrease the presence of the NPT 2 and
NPT to see proteins at the level of the
brush membrane on the level of the urine
information so there will be less
reabsorption of as fat increase for
spatula and so in constic also decrease
in phosphate a Nia you must note that
PTH and f GF 23 both hypophosphatemia
common but they have opposite effects on
the metal on metabolism of vitamin D you
understood that
PTH stimulates the secretion of 125 di
proximity determined in the kidney at
fgf 23 decrease this secretion of course
everybody of you know that the
definition of CKD is based on the GFR
glomerular filtration rate which is
assessed by the crack created in
concentration and after applying some
formula M G oo D or ckd-epi formula and
the different stage of CKD
are based on zero you have here the
definition that of course you know you
must know that
Sakuni is really a public's public s
problem with depends on the country
almost 10% of the population who add
zero below sixty and the main causes of
CKD you know is Table two hypertension
and many other causes one problem is
that the diagnosis of CKD is a fondant
very late when the patient is already in
end-stage renal disease and so many
patients go to dialysis in emergency
with many problem or any consequence and
there are many complications of CKD with
increased mortality especially of
cardiovascular cause and on on the
speech I will focus on what we call the
CKD mineral and bone disorders so don't
be afraid that please by this slide you
know an interval of a second sick
metabolism the first thing which happens
when the GFR decreases is a trend in an
increase forsythia and the consequence
is an immediate increase not immediate
an increase in objections III secretion
by the bone the bone is the main organ
that produced subject registry the
consequence of increased fgf dentistry
of course is a decrease reabsorption of
first part we will trend to normalize
transfer tamiya but also the increased
address dentistry will decrease as i
told you in the previous slide the final
synthesis of the active metabolite of
intervened a which which will decrease
the absorption of phosphide bicycles
also aiming to normalize phosphate area
but also the decrease synthesis of can
see trial will decrease the absorption
of calcium by the goods which will trend
to decrease in consumer and also the
decreased
120 fire will have a [ __ ] second so
decrease feedback of secretion of adh
the consequence of which is an increase
in PTH secretion which is called celery
I brought you a tease this high level of
PTH could be very variable from one
patient to another and it may be
exacerbated by many reasons for example
the sort of resistance retention in the
balloon less receptive of vitamin D in
the pathways and so on so this slide
describes the mechanism simplified
mechanism of what we call the Sun glory
I proper authorities of chronic in the
disease among the consequence of the
disordered metabolism of calcium and
phosphate you know we have a lot of
potentially a lot of alliteration of
bone Tolliver and somatically we have
two main situation hi bonthorn of our
disease which is jus associated with
high effect of pH and low both of your
disease so called a dynamic Osteopathy
which is associated or which is due to
decrease the effects of but of course
other reason may occur for example
osteomalacia which is a defect in the
bone mineralization also it's not
written on this slide osteoporosis which
is which is a bone fragility with an
increased risk of fracture you must know
that sick annotations or given bone
mineral density as a more risk of
fracture than somebody for the same bone
mineral density with no CKD and you know
high bond tolliver and low bond on we're
both associated in second emissions with
an higher risk of mortality however you
know the term of renal osteodystrophy
now it's it must be you know kept for
the bone anomalies that are detected on
bone DFC bone biopsy being the reference
method to assess bone turnover
especially not only insecurity issues we
also have a treatment that our target
for stochastic metabolism for
never geez want to decrease vespa tamiya
with skeletor's of phosphate which maybe
cabinet of calcium or non kelsey
collaterals but also to decrease by the
age for example in dialysis patient the
nephrologist may modify the
concentration of calcium in the dialysis
bath news also vitamin D or 25 hydroxy
vitamin D we can use also one
hydroxylated the vitamin d compounds
such as calcitriol or drugs which are
considered modified LCpl and also drugs
called calcium emetics the cinematix are
drug that mimics and activation of the
calcium something receptor an increase
in calcium and the one which is a very
much prescribed in second division is
called cynical set okay let me now
introduce international guidelines for
the differences which are called the KD
goo guidelines and I will focus on the
código guidelines director of the
world's CKD mineral and bone disorders
these guidelines were published in 2009
and they were updated last year and they
replaced the previous gas guideline
called the Kato key guidelines which
were published in 2003 you must know
that the clinical recommendation are
graded in fact each recommendation of
suggestion is characterized by a number
level one is a strong recommendation for
the majority of the security patience
and level 2 is a simple suggestion and
beside the number one or two there is a
letter a B C or D which characterized
the cavity of the evidence may be being
very high visions with in fact no
recommendation with labor a and D
corresponding to a very uncertain level
of a video supportive evidence but in my
experience even a simple suggestion with
a poor level of evidence is considered
to be better to be far away than to do
nothing
okay I will start my description of the
omen by P th party ordered tea right oh
man you know that it is a small peptide
made of 84 amino acid and that the three
n-terminal amino acid are necessary for
the Iron Curtain semuc I poof us with a
big effect of the but there are many
fragments of PTH that cells then
circulates in the blood stream many what
we call c-terminal fragment that of
course inactive but they accumulate in
CKD and I will speak I will stick also
later in another slide of the special
fragment which is in fact the 184 intact
PTH which lacks the six first amino acid
here on the n-terminal part of the
molecule so which is the 784 PTH Ragland
oops this is the first recommendation
that I will describe well PT action
comes and which deal with the frequency
of measurement of pH in the CKD patient
so start measuring package here from
stage 3 which means GFR below 60 you
know there is a reason are monitoring
and tell valves between measurement of
PTH look for example in the stage 5
including dialysis patients in this
patient is sick and in stage 5 D is
proposed to measure P - every three to
six months in France in my experience
it's more often than every three months
so for the clinical laboratory PTH
measurement in second divisions is
something which is very often prescribed
this slide describes you know the
frequency of measurement of PTH to be
done in stable patient but in fact look
at this sentence in second D patients
with boo receive treatment for CKD
MBD mineral and bone disorders or in
room
by opening part biochemical
abnormalities are you don't defend for
example the high pH level it is
reasonable to increase the frequency of
measurement for example if you find a
high pH too high for the CKD stage the
nephrologist will probably do something
therapeutic attitude to decrease PTH and
most repeat eh
before the recommended delay of my
example three months in the Pegasus
patient you see that for the código
expert in indicial who are not in
disease stage three to five the optimal
PTH level is not known the experts
suggest that in patients will avail of
PTH which are above the upper lower
limit of the SI they should evaluate if
the patient is I prefer Swati me
hypocalcemic or if he or she has vitamin
D deficiency and correct this anomaly so
the target seems to me montane PTH well
within the normal range of the of the SA
in fact in my experience with my
nephrologist colleague I know that in
patient with you know left stage without
failure for example Stage five or late
stage for many prefer to keep the PTH
level around twice the normal limit of
the SF
what is duties in the in the lab now I
will focus on the dialysis patient and
discuss the difference between the
kurakin
recommendation of the kiddo key
guidelines remember provision 2003 and
the que digo guidelines published in
2009 now in the key to kill the
recommendation in dialysis patient was
to maintain pH within range 150 to 300
pick one Tommy leave it in the caddy go
headlines the recommendation was to
maintain PTH which
twice to nine times the upper limit of
normal so these two recommendation of
traditions seems very different and this
in my opinion deserves a lot of
discussion but before going further
further
look at this recommendations with E
which is in fact the recommendation one
number one with the highest level of
evidence b1 B is the strongest or
combination clinical laboratories must
keep the nephrologist inform about the
PDF I said that they use with a special
alert in case of oxygen could be funny
in fact that in guidelines which are for
the nephrologist the strongest
recommendations conserve the clinical
laboratory here again we need some
discussion you must remember that in the
case of key guidelines the target range
for the dialysis patients maintain peak
age between within 150 and tentacled
mill was based in fact on both the
abscissa to deal but well done in the
early 90s and the results of the bone
biopsy were compared to PTH level which
were assessed with historical second
generation and say called the radical
eth assay the Anacapa th assay was in
fact the first circle generation pradesh
assay that was used for several years
maybe three to five years and not not
true in most of maybe all laboratories
in the world that module PTH it was a
radioactive in module two metric si and
after a few years of course in the early
nineties many other I say became
available and some we also had active
battles over where automated PT edges so
with this a de Grasse the target 150 to
300 picogram per million daily suspicion
was considered
at the best best chance in the vanity
station to have a normal bone Tolliver
but of course on the clinical laboratory
point of view important question maybe a
skirt you know while in the Kentucky
guidelines this ranch of concentration
150 to 300 was proposed whatever the
interpretation is say the question could
be are you sure how is sure that all pts
is say provide on a given serum I mean
the same concentration of course the
reason is clearly no see we published
this to D in 2006 in fact we perform the
stood in 2005 it was a period when the
addict USA was still available and a few
months after it disappeared from the
market in this 2d we measured the PTH
with the 15 PTH si which were at this
moment available in France and use in
the laboratories and we measure PTH in
72 pools of serum from dialysis patients
I will summarize for example we found
that when the other group PTH gave for
example 150 peak of one per meal which
is a low west limit of the diocese
target range in the kazuki-sama say
could give 8080 which means too low PTH
level and then effigies has to do
something therapeutic attitude to
increase PTH while also I say can this
one could give 300 here swindle treats
23 which is a level above the target
range which will also induce at repeated
attitude but in the opposite direction
in this case the nephrologist we want to
decrease pH so according to the PTH
assay which is used the nephrologist may
have opposite therapeutic particular of
course this is absolutely unacceptable
table and the código expert decided to
modify the target range for that is the
station that was proposing the in the
pedo key problem is a how could we solve
this problem and of course the first
idea is to standardize the pts essays
before going further oh here again a
small shot remaining you know that
currently we membership attached with to
kind of assess the second generation
essays and the third generation pts
essays in fact the tooth these two
generation of essays differ in terms of
appetit epitope recognition you know the
ulti n-terminal antibody of the second
generation is say hello they say to
measure both the 184 intact PTH but also
the 784 pts fragment while the solar the
third generation pts assay because the
Archean terminal antibody is directed
again the four first amino acid in the
n-terminal part do not matter 784 si
elders only measure 184 village two
problems the 784 pts fragments
accumulates in CKD and its percentage
I mean relative to 184 th seems to be
highly variable from one person to
another
in fact some studies suggest that in the
serum of a diabetes patient there is as
much 184 integrity ash as 784 P th
fragment but with a huge variability
from one person to another in the civil
problem if that the second generation
PTH I said that also measure 784 PTH
fragment
I've in fact very variable cross
reactivity for this seven
for fragment sub I says by simple cross
read approximately 50% with a 784 pts
fragment and other essays cross-react
$200 maybe more than hundreds so suppose
in the serum of the dye disease patient
which contain health 184 and while
health 784 PTH and say a concentration
of 400 peacock one Camille with the
second generation as said that mother
with android prescribed a notice on core
activities a seven- of fragments of
course with another PTA she said that
cross right at about 50% you won't have
the concentration of 400 picogram per
meal even if the choices are
standardized even if the gives the same
concentration of the solution of study
of recombinant PTH for example in the
case of a Ana sale that cross rack to
50% you will have something like 300
pickle I promise so in fact we can study
dice PTH but to store the other is PTH
they say we need a reference method
which could be with no dubbed liquid
chromatography mass spectrometry method
which currently does not exist with
satisfaction in fact probably this may
be improved Sula as I know that several
groups are working on developing LCMS
method for PTH but it is not the case we
need a international stronger we are
but of course due to the different cost
activity of the second generation it
Yasha says with the 784 fragments we
cannot consider that the essay will be
standardized in the sir for the serum of
patients in fact the full
standardization of PTH essays can only
be achieved with the served generations
as say which we believe on
184 pillage so maybe we can use other
solution to solve the problem of
automated viability of the PDS SS for
example applying correction factor to
give an essay or use toggle pts
concentration that are specific or entry
7 clearly these solutions are not
satisfying when the different gist
understood that the PTA she said did not
give would do not give the same
concentration on the given Serena they
also consider that the prefer one as I
give higher values than and although I
say this I say that give higher values
should have higher upper limit of normal
values higher normal values and so
instead of using PTH target range in
dialysis patient that is based on
absolute concentration in Pico contour
mill they preferred to propose a target
range that is based on multiple of the
upper limit of normal in of the of each
essay that's why they proposed to keep
the PTH of die dissipation within two to
nine times the upper limit of normal of
the essay you see is to see so it's a
simple suggestion one thing also you can
understand that 9 times upper limit of
normal if for those who use the link opt
age is say you remember that upper limit
of normal was 65 token per meal if you
multiply 65 by 9 you are far from 300
won per meal which will which was an
upper limit of the target of the karaoke
nine times 65 is 585 so it's a hopper
limit for the target range for disease
and this is due to the fact that in more
recent studies
hi PTH level around 600 pickle one per
meal with the alley
I say we're only this high pitiable were
associated with an increased mortality
okay this is a very elegant proposition
you know but once again from the
clinical level 3.0 point of view we can
ask another question are we sure that
the reference values for all the potage
keys are comparable you know they are
they have not been established in the
scene in the same population so are they
comparable and once again the response
in my opinion is clearly new here I show
table that we extracted from paper on
Attock that we publish with my
colleagues and friend I would say better
of my friends and colleagues HM Cavalia
and P adelinechan carry the clinical
chemistry holidays nephrologist from the
Liege University in the Belgium in this
study in the lab of HN Cavalli PTH was
measured with 10 different PTSA in 280
LC subjects with the 25 hydroxy vitamin
D above 13 and a grand premiere which is
$75 college so these subjects are no
vitamin D deficiency in the GFR above 60
so no CKD in the right color how what we
found in the 280 subjects so this may
correspond to our reference values for
each of these ten kids and on this color
on the middle column you have the
manufacturer's reference values in fact
which are used in most laboratory look
at the first line you see that our upper
limit is very very close to the one of
the manufacturers 65 68
clearly no big difference but look at
the last line our upper limit of normal
is 47 with this key
in the same population while it is 88 so
almost the double by the manufacturer if
we look to do to the other line to the
other I say you may find that that a
whirl upper limit of normal is between
25 and 30 percent less than the one of
the manufacturer and if we translate
that into the category target range for
disease patient two to nine times the
upper limit of normal you can see that
and look again at the last line with
this I say in suder's with this has a
dialysis patient with PTH level of say
650 typical conformity it is clearly
clearly above the targets with our
reference much it is within the target
with the manufacturer around and so once
again the nephrologist may have two
different attitude according to the
normal values that are you know use for
this assay in a given laboratory I want
to say also but in this 2d we measure
PTH in more than 100 dionysus patient in
the university hospital with the
stennheiser
and we show the figure where we compare
the classification of the patients with
the two second-generation PT as I said
that gave the most different values is
what the architect which gave the
highest value and the entire Ummah that
gave the low was very a classification
of the patient's means he's a patient
who is in the target range above of
below the target range in fact when we
use the caddy guitar guitar Ange base
and the manufacturer normal values in
fact almost approximately 30% of the
patients we are classified differently
means with one si the patient is in the
target and with the other se
above or below the target when we use
our reference values to for the category
target range in fact almost all patients
were classified similarly so I see that
a very big work international work
should be done to recruit a very antsy
population with no reason of having a
high or low PTH for example as we did
with no vitamin D deficiency with no low
jefra but other reasons of modifying PT
PT age to collect enough blood to merge
the PTH with all the PTH kids that are
available and maybe keeping some blue
the some serum to measure PTH win the
future market which will be developed
later and so that we may have a
reference value normal values for P th
that are comparable at means that have
been established from the same
population and I believe I am NOT the
only one who believe that I believe that
this may decrease the difference of
classification that could be done using
the category target trans for the
inspection with the different Padilla
says okay this is the last slide on PTH
with the last recommendation it's a
recommendation 1c I read the
recommendation in patients with CKD
stage 3 to 5 days including the very
special
we recommend that therapeutic decisions
be based on trends rather than a single
laboratory are you this means that
suppose a Thai disease patients in whom
PTH is measured in the target range if
the previous measurement made for
example three months before is
significantly different the nephrologist
should do something to modify PTH for
example if the
- has increased significantly from the
previous measurement the nephrologist
should try to decrease pH once again one
question from the clinical laboratory
point of view what does the significant
difference between two 80s levels Nina
to know that we have to calculate what
is called the critical difference which
in fact is a calculation based on the
analytical coefficient of variation of
PSA but more important on the biological
coefficient of variation and in fact I
saw only one study that there have been
several to do one with bio eighteen
Germany my friend I showed it one you
see that the critical difference for
dialysis patients is finally quite
height or very high 72 percent in this
in this 2d this means that if you
clinical clinical laboratory manager
find that the PTH in the dialysis
patients as increased or decreased by
more than according to this to the
seventy two percent you should inform
the de franchis who should modify
something to make that the PTH go come
back to its initial level so it's
complicated but it means also that the
clinical laboratory manager has to
discuss with the nephrologist and
they've reduced us to discuss with the
clinical laboratory manager of
saturation Solomon is recommending you
know if you consider the definition of
bitumen bitumen is something a compound
that you need in small quantity
otherwise you are sick but that you
cannot synthesize you cannot make you
know that the main source of vitamin D
in fact is
as like this slide is in fact the skin
synthesis of vitamin D when your skin
skin is exposed to UVB radiation release
the Sun so according to this definition
vitamin D you know it's not a real
vitamin it is also vitamin because there
are some data resource such as a marine
fatty fatty fish eggs are ingested or
either synthesized by the skin the
vitamin D is transported by a vitamin D
protein and is transformed into 25 i
grok c vitamin d in the labor and 25 i
rock system in day the compound with a
long half-life 25 I was interning there
may be that transform in the proximal
tubule of the kidney into 125 the
hydroxy vitamin D also called you do now
can see try this several transformation
in the proximal tubule is in fact very
tightly regulated the most important
stimulator is PTH to do before and it's
inhibitor is actually have 23 of course
about other reason 125gr exhibit a min
they pass into the bloodstream and in
tissue that are distant from the
producer then it binds to a citizen ik
receptor the video with them in their
receptor to exert genomic action so you
have a compound 125 G alkoxy vitamin D
which is produced by an organ go in the
bloodstream and in distance binds to
receptor and this is a perfect
definition of almond 125 gr exhibited
mendicancy trial is a hormone and 25
hydroxy vitamin D is a pre OMA you know
so that many almost all tissues in the
body which has nothing to do with the
gal calcium phosphate or bone metabolism
in fact may Express the vitamin D
receptor and also the enzymatic
machinery that active
it's every time in the 25 hydroxy
vitamin D into 125 and 25 hydroxy
vitamin day is able to enter these
different tissues and be transformed
locally in the cell into 125 which will
bind to the local written in the
receptor to exerts local genomic effects
and clearly 125 doesn't go out of the
cell to participate to the calcium
phosphate metabolism this site is the
basis of the so-called potential non
classical effort of vitamin D
non-classical effects main known for
social cycle benefit and finally we also
know that there is a inactivating
pathway for vitamin D so instead of
being transformed into 125 CC diamond a
25-hour proximately may be transformed
into 2425 inactive vitamin D and we now
know that it's elective pathway is very
important because if you like it for
example in case of inactivity in
activating mutation of the gene that
encodes the 24 hydroxy lines you cannot
make 2425 you are very sick very
hypocalcemic and surely with renal
damage such as miracle synergies okay
you know of course you know that the
serum 25 D concentration is the marker
of vitamin D status and this is a
consensus but normal 25 D concentration
must not be established from and
apparently as the population must be
population base as we say instead it
should be based for example on the 25 D
concentration that are associated with
pathological cone situation and of
course should be avoided but better now
that we have some randomized control
trials that have shown
better effect of vitamin D than of
placebo it should be based on the 25 d
the levels that were Richard in the
vitamin D group of this randomized
control trial this is also I think a
consensus the problem is that the
experts have become in the expert do not
seem to agree on the threefold 25 D
threshold that defined optimality time
in these stages many consider that 25 D
above 20 nanogram per mil which is 15
animal collateral is sufficient for most
while others are for 30 nano gram
protein which is $75 in my opinion we
may differentiate general population
most and see subjects in whom I believe
that 20 nano gram per meal is really
sufficient and we have not to measure 25
D in this subject and also some patients
for example osteoporosis patient maybe
secondly may be patient with the
malabsorption sacrum he whom I think
personally everybody is not of course in
agreement with me but maybe you agree
with me in whom I think that 13 under
control is better okay back to the CKD
patient and this is a figure from
elastic which described French Court of
CKD patient not on dialysis in this to D
vitamin D deficiency was defined as a 25
G level between below excuse me 15
nanogram Pramila
why normality was 25 G above 13 and
Pramila and as you can see here the
frequency of deficiency increase with
the CKD stage more frequent in end-stage
renal but I think more interesting is
that those with vitamin D deficiency 50
below 15
compared to those with no mala according
to the study vitamin D status 2530 had
more frequently significantly more
frequently hypocalcemia highborn
Tolliver defined by I bone alkaline
phosphatase and IC TX low 125 and high
PTH a new trend
unknown significant rain much close to
significant trade in more frequent
hypophosphatemia of course this is
observational but I think it's quite
interesting but now why should we
maintain an optimal vitamin D status
insecurity patients optimal with a
majestic status mean good concentration
of 25 G I mean both on dialysis and non
daily discussion and why should we
measure a serum to affect the
concentration first observational
studies show that low 25-day in CKD is
associated with in known disease
patients but also in a renal transplant
recipient with a faster decline in
jeffra in dialysis and non-religious
seek adapation
low 25-day is in many studies associated
with iOS or and PTH levels and indices
and non delicious low 25 D is associated
with higher risk of cardiovascular and
all cause mortality I is reference to
meta-analysis of observational studies
and also low 25 D is associated with
lower bone mineral density both at the
spine habitable and at the FASFA one
like more cortical bone
so this observation Allah may be better
what happens when you give it a midday
with vitamin D supplementation
you'll have many students that show that
vitamin D supplementation in CKD both
diocese and
mrs. patience decreases P - P th even in
small quite recent randomized control
trials which means vitamin D versus
placebo in the few and small studies
some are randomized vitamin D
supplementation in non dialysis patients
of course improves on total dysfunction
and decrease albumin earlier
fiber per second a state sweet offer so
it's not a recommendation it's a simple
submission the código says inpatient
with CKD stage 3b stage 3b it's below
forty five to thirty four the jeffra we
suggest that 25 t level might be
measured and repeating testing is
determinate by baseline value and
therapeutic intervention which means
that if you find a low 25 deliver in
palaces or non biosecurity patients the
nephrologist should provide vitamin D or
25 at work symptom in day and 25 this
should it should be measure again after
some weeks on nose okay you know that
the measurement of 125 is not
recommended by the nephrologist except
of course in some cases of unexplained
ifalcon semia with look at the age in
the second occasion you have not to
measure 125 but don't forget that the
measurement of 125 is very important in
some situations we are closed more close
to on the chronology for example in any
case of hypocalcemia or civil
unexplained I park an area with low Vth
of course you should measure 125 also of
course in any case of vitamin D
resistance rickets
to understand what is the cause of this
I will finish my speech with some slides
about what maybe some of you or many of
you know less this new quite new urban
fgf 23 you understood that it is a hyper
fast rhetoric hypophosphatemia cold
blood which is secreted by bone cells
mostly osteocytes and of students and
you see the number of publication on
pre-med increase slightly during more
than 10 years but increase a lot in this
last last year with I did this
PowerPoint in September you see much
higher odd number of publication in
there in per med and really I believe
that every f23 is a hot topic for
researcher but also for nephrologist you
must understand that object 23 is a
glucose related peptide of 251 amino
acid and this peptide as a short F out
of life it is secreted by the bone he
will act to decrease phosphate amia in
christmas betrayer but it is rapidly
flavored into a to inactive fragment one
n-terminal and one c terminal fragment
and we are able to measure electrical
current here on plasma EDTA plasma with
different essays sermon recognize only
the active in black peptide they are
called intact jeff 23 Isis and other
recognize both the intact peptide and
the C terminal in active fragment and
they are called C terminal fgf 23 s a
black oscillation is important for every
Flandreau to stabilize the molecule and
this is under the control of an awesome
which is called gal and history i told
about the runway and don't remember I
have to if I talk about that the
receptor of object in history
in fact a complex of two molecule one of
the four fgf receptor was key a GF r1
which is associated with the
transmembrane protein a cool Cruiser you
know now that fgf 23 inhibits the
reabsorption of phosphate in the
proximal tubule
by decreasing the presence on the brush
mode morale of the true sodium phosphate
code hospital and PT 2 a and n PT to see
and you know now also that
fgf 23 control the metabolism of can see
trial in the kidney it decreases the
synthesis of calcitriol and something I
did not say it stimulates the expression
of the 24 hydroxy does so in activating
vitamin D if this is out of CKD
just two slides if you have an excess
you produce an excess of FF 23 you have
you are sick and there are two kind of
disease some may be acquired like Tamar
induced
osteomalacia which is due to small
tumors mostly Bening that's secret
object in history and also disease could
be of genetic origin the most frequent
being extinct I profess with any
crickets all the reasons of it is not a
topic of my speech and this situation
share a similar phenotype of rickets
in children osteomalacia in adults who
is a diffuse pain the risk of fracture
and so on you know that but also a
similar or quite a similar biological
phenotype with hypophosphatemia and I
profess Natalia Lu Tien po2 jefra luang
normal can see trio 125 low or normal
consider consider excuse me
normal high PTH and like in any rickets
or coastal Malaysia a high level of
in hospitals so if you have too much you
have 20 C you have sick you are sick if
you like objected history also you are
sick
these are rare disease for example
mutation in the James 4hf 23 or in the
chain of proto which induce a resistance
to average of 23 and more frequently or
so it is not frequent a mutation in the
gene that encodes the on Zima because in
later objected 23 remember gal and
history and in this case the patients
are hypotheses emic and on the clinical
point of view that develop extra
skeletal calcification which shall some
time look at this figure very very very
impressive okay back to the security
patients this table represents the fgf
23 concentration that we obtain with the
intact fgf 23 a say on the Rezo excel
from gesturing here are what we obtain
in normal subjects or more than 900
normal subjects very well phenotyped
this is not seek additional induces to
Malaysia or x-linked a type of speakers
but here how the last five lines are
sick addition what you see in that very
early in secondly even in stage 3 a when
a burst 3a is Jennifer from sixty to
forty five you have an increase clearly
and clearly an increase look at look at
the mean here in the concentration of
objectin tissue and you see that the
concentration continue to increase
throughout the course of CKD to become
very very very high in dialysis patient
see here it is more than 100 times
higher than in normal subjects look also
to the big difference between the Minah
here and the median here of the value
obtained
their suspicions which suggests that
there is a subpopulation of dailies
especially with a very very very high FG
of 23 concentration and in fact in now
quite a large number of articles it was
found an association between those daily
specials with the highest level of 25
fgf 23 excuse me and an increased risk
of mortality I show just as an example
to students in dialysis patients but
this was also fine found in many studies
in non dynasties secondes patients and
this is mercy they're very opportunity
but many many Arctic as published that
one single so is that in the the paper
that they present in the two previous
slides fgf 23 was measured at a single
diamond and in this paper published very
recently in fact the hotel use at
respectively a CKD non disease CKD
cohort named the creek quote and they
measured secondary objective to 3 in
Mena four times a year in some patient
it was less than four times in those
efficient it was more than four times
but in mean it was four times for
example every three months and they
found that but in fact FJ 23 was
relatively stable in most patients it's
here but in some patients abject 23
increase slowly and in other patients it
increased more quickly and in those
patients in whom abject 23 increased
slowly the risk of death was more than
four times higher than in zode with
stable object 23 concentration look here
in those patients with an
first increase in fgf 23 concentration
the rest of this was 15 times more than
50 higher than in those with a stable
concentration so of course we can
consider that the level of evidence is
not perfect it is not perfect it is a
height respective study but it suggests
overall that serial measurement of fgf
23 may be a very good prognostic marker
of Nobby mortality in ii ii ii ii
patients of course this deserves new
thousand students so as a summary of
many many studies fgf 23 in ii ii
patients daily
higher object 23 level associated with
an increase raised cover many baba kety
cardiovascular mortality myocardial
infraction stroke left ventricular
hypertrophy and so on but once again
these curves from observational studies
and we must address the question of
causality in fact is address 23
responsible may be only in part of the
morbidity scene cardiovascular mobility
seen in his patients can I cannot
respond a totally to this question but I
would like to show you only one result
of one very good paper published in 2011
in a very good Journal of science
Journal of Clinical Investigation in
this 2d fgf 23 was injected infused - I
mean infuse in the health
archive on tricular infusion to mice in
which the gene for crew to remember the
concept of real 5:23 was invalidated
deleted and this here is the influence
every of 23 and here it is the infusion
of a vehicle what could be a possible
you know when we tested great okay and
you see clearly a huge yeah cardiac
hypertrophy after the injection of age
of 23 so interestingly in the study in
mice mice are not humans but in life MGF
2023 directly injected in the health was
responsible of the cardiac hypertrophy
and also very interestingly this
deleterious effects of every 23 on
health health was did not need the
presence of crew to presence of co2
absolutely necessary for the
hypophosphatemia type of rhetoric effect
of FJ 23 but it doesn't does not seem to
be necessary for the vascular the later
use effects of very high levels of
objective this way i will not comment
since this results were to save time but
i want to ask a question okay does the
decrease of plasma object industry
prevent tragic typography and also of
mortality was promoter ET in humans and
alas we we have no clear answer for that
you know different way to decrease
actually of 23 did not show an
improvement in the vascular elves or
better produced ik of of the CKD
patients in whom this was done or
unsecured patients may be except this 2d
with cynical said remember cynical said
is a calcium emetic that mimics
hypocalcemia it makes that PTH decreases
i just show you one figure it is a
factor secondary analysis of a very nice
randomized control trial didn't die
disease patients cynical said versus
placebo the trail was called evolve
study and the transepts
article was published in the New England
Journal of Medicine in fact more than
300 mm excuse me ladies patients were
randomized among which 2000 2600
patients had both baseline and week 20
evidence 23 measurement has 23 values so
you understand that cynical said
decrease PTH
you know that PTH in under chronology is
a hypophosphatemia common but it is a
hypophosphatemia common because it
decreased the reabsorption of phosphate
in the proximal tubular increasing vs.
Australia but in dialysis patient where
there is no functional proximal tubular
PTH becomes hypophosphatemia because
also PTH release you know cancer but
also first part from 2 so when you
decrease PTH you may decrease in the
disease patients I mean you may decrease
a sweaty look at these results
this is the group that received cynical
said this is the group that received
placebo
you know after 20 weeks I've GF 10 to 3
did not change in the placebo group but
it decreased but ultimately health in
the cynical set group this was a mean
decrease which means some decrease more
some decrease less in this figure it is
a comparison of basis patient who
decreased fgf 23 by more than 50%
compared to those that decrease of just
which is RIBA less than a 50% and in
those would decrease of just in history
by more than 50 percent there is a
significant you see the p-value here on
the on the right there is a significant
decrease in many outcomes such as
cardiovascular mortality or composite
outcome of
cardiovascular events in that and mati
of course this is a retrospective study
the heavens 2d was not performed to
evaluate what happens when we decrease
fgf dentistry but it is a first study
that shows an improvement in the outcome
of the cicada patient when you decrease
of Jeff did you see at easy due to this
improvement to a decrease in a drift in
this way or is it due to a decrease in
in PTH also I don't know what we don't
know and this needs further studies oops
so this is my last slide in summary
about fgf 23 you know that after the
discovery of the draft and history and
of the sodium prostatic advanced
processor we were very happy because
this has greatly improved our knowledge
and phosphate metabolism and you
understood that both excess and lack of
address dentistry in patients with
normal renal function as a responsible
for disease hypophosphatemia disease
when you have too much preferred history
I prefer swimming disease when you let
to jeff 23 ofjust twenties wave effects
and of course I think that abject 23
measurement in plasma is very important
in patient with phosphate disorders now
after a 23 measurement in sick any
patients may be more in disease patients
possibly is potentially very interesting
as a predictor of cardiovascular body
body Authority and may be according to
one paper that I shown you the several
measurement of FJ 23 and the evolution
of its concentration when it's in the
increase it seems to be a very bad
prognosis for the patients of course one
again mod more data are needed to
include a drift and history measurement
in the biological survey of second CKD
MPD and especially to evaluate what
happens when object and history
concentration is decreased by a given
treatment either clearly an improvement
in the outcome in the portal
of the patient so I stop here and I
thank you for your attention
Thank You Jean Claude for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left your screen Emel answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is in which diseases in your
opinion useful the dosage of the 2508
vitamin D first I think that 25 this
shouldn't be measured in there in the
general population in my opinion it is
very important in patients with what we
call bone fragility such as osteoporosis
or suspicion over stimulation and so any
bone disease as I told you before in the
SE queda patients both CKD which are in
Titus's and in nan de disease according
to the category commendation i think it
is also important in any patient with a
malabsorption syndrome for example
celiac disease Crohn's syndrome
inflammatory bowel disease or you know
after passage biotics of jewelry by
bypass this is very important also I
think it is important in any case of
patients with an expiration of calcium
phosphate phosphate metabolism which
includes the PTH measurement for me
these are the main indication of 25 D
measurements now our next question which
normal range for PTH do we have to refer
to in our lab okay and of course it will
depends on the essay that is used as I
told you in my slides I think that so
very often the magnified
to repeat each normal values are not
adapted to the clinical situation what I
can say is that in our lab we used the
reference values that I showed to you in
one of my slide I adapted from a paper
by H and Cavalli a PRN a and B so you
have to go back to to my slides I think
that normal values for P th should be
established in the population who has no
reason of having for example of high or
low Vth for example healthy population
with no vitamin D deficiency or
insufficiency with a normal rain
infection and no reason of having high
or low PTH so I can I cannot say for all
I says but let me suggest to go back to
our arctic I think every AP of the
lineage of consumable published in
nephrology values and transplantation
you look at the reference that I put in
my slide for PTH results should we
report the que digo recommendations X 2
X 9 yes my opinion is is yes for the
disease patients only the disease
patient I think the best for the lab
manager it is to speak with the
nephrologist and ask the refugees if he
is interested by this report I think
it's a good it's a good thing to do it's
an improvement in their in what you you
for further help to the patient of
course this means that you have a
well-defined that was a previous
question your reference value and your
limit of normal but yes but really
discuss with the nephrologist and ask
her if she is interested made that now
jean-claude our next question is a
two-part question in the long term will
the SG f23 be a biomarker
userroutine and will it replace other
parameters like for example the PTH okay
okay so in the long term yes I think
that potentially objects with this river
is a very interesting marker in second
divisions of course it is for me a
routine measurement in patients
currently in patients who is hypo or
hyper for specific disease for doing the
diagnosis but if we speak of CKD
patients I think that it could be in the
long term a very interesting marker but
as I told you in my presentation
currently we lack a sufficient stood
especially relax to DS that clearly
clearly show that if you decrease
objects and especially in diabetes
patients I think you will improve their
outcome so if some studi accumulates
with this kind of reserves of course
objection to three will become a marker
currently we don't know what to do with
an elevated level of every 23 the second
part of the question was do I think that
Jeff 23 measurement could replace for
example PTH measurement first I don't
think so and I think also that if you
ask that - most nephrologist they won't
be okay probably moved many want to add
object 23 but they don't want to stop
measuring bth and it looks like we have
time for one more question you have been
talking about hormones useful for the
management of CKD patients recommended
by the KD po guidelines which are the
other parameters that should be
performed routinely I will only consider
parameters in the field of a CKD mineral
and bone disorders I think it is very
useful
- had a bone turnover marker one problem
with the bull Tolliver markers is that
most molecules are eliminate eliminated
by the canary in case of chronic kidney
disease especially in dialysis patient
they accumulate in the blood and they
are not very informative so in my
opinion currently the best and easily
per from Bolton of a marker is born
alkaline phosphatase and I think it is
useful to add bone alkaline phosphatase
to the panel of of marker I just talked
about their word but I think it's a good
complementary you know ever in some
patient in cancer very very high-paid
age because some resistant to PTH occurs
may be a big resistance with the edge
occurs in disease patients you may have
quite a low bun turnover and also but
it's a little bit out not totally out of
this field I think many groups are
looking for markers of vascular
calcification which is a real burden in
these patients I think we are not at the
point where we have a clear marker to
use in the future
I think we have to look to the markers
products of vascular calcification for
the second edition and this one of these
macro may be some markers could be
included to their to their evaluation of
the patients thank you again
jean-claude for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank laberd's and our sponsor dias Oren
for underwriting today's educational
webcasts before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through june of 2019 leverets Woolery
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that you know
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's life of it until next time
goodbye